[Music]
DreamWorks Animation released the new
trailer for How to Train Your Dragon the
hidden world and it's pretty awesome we
found out some pretty interesting facts
and dark secrets about the upcoming
movie including one that broke our
hearts if you're new to the things
channel click that notification bell so
you don't miss our new videos now check
out these dark secrets and fun facts
about How to Train Your Dragon the
hidden world
toothless almost looks like a parrot so
anyone who has watched the How to Train
Your Dragon movies knows that toothless
is a black Night Fury and those awesome
dragon ever but here's a secret that you
may not know about our favorite dragon
according to dreamworks TV the creator's
almost made him green and red instead of
black also they were going to make
toothless much much smaller about the
size of a green and red parrot on hiccup
shoulder after some debate the creators
decided to use a different animal for
inspiration they added the
characteristics of a Panther to make him
a totally relatable and unique dragon
toothless has a girlfriend hiccup and
toothless have outgrown each other this
is more of a sad reality than a dark
secret but it seems that toothless and
hiccups time together may be coming to a
close it's clear from the beard in the
trailer that hiccup grows up a lot and
toothless seems to I found a companion
in the light fury dragon they discover
now director Dean Dubois revealed that
the story does bounce around in the
timeline but he also shared that he
loves the wonderful and bittersweet
aspect to the friendship between hiccup
and toothless even if they must part
ways they will forever be changed by one
another we're not crying they are trying
to make us cry
and speaking of crying what is it with
animated films that jerk the tears right
out of our sad little faces in an
interview with slash film comm director
Dean Dubois admits that he was
intentionally out to make the audience
cry he said that the intent is to have
the audience share all the fields with
the characters from the fun and
adventures aspect to the fright and
peril but he shared that he thinks that
the Wonder and emotion are the most
important moments and that he hopes to
bring the audience to tears so you might
want to stock up on tissues before going
to see this movie
Astrid wasn't in the books according to
some
critics the movies are lacking a bit in
the girl-power Department the original
book series doesn't even have a female
character named Astrid one critic said
that the female character for the movie
was created solely for the purpose of
the romantic subplot another critic said
that Astrid is pretty much there from
the beginning to be the reward for
hiccup hiccup even said at the beginning
that he wants to become successful so he
can get a girlfriend critics think
Astrid has been reduced to just a prize
to be won even if she is a cooler edgier
stronger prize than other female
characters there is a hidden message
about intolerance in the hidden world
Dean Dubois shared that there is a
hidden theme in the hidden world that
you'll notice if you pay attention he
said there is a new villain named
grimille and grizzly who believes all
dragons are vermin and should be
destroyed diblock called him a very
intolerant character he said that
knowing what we know about dragons
it makes grimille and grizzly seem
especially cruel and rigid the ugliness
of intolerance is brought to life by him
hiccups idealism and hope-filled
attitude is a stark contrast to that
hatred shown by the villain hiccup
believes that coexistence is possible
but not everyone sees it that way
dreamer expired a bunch of employees
there were many delays in the releasing
of this third How to Train Your Dragon
movie this is because a bunch of
DreamWorks Animation employees got fired
according to Variety magazine the job
cuts came after a string of
disappointments at the box office we are
no longer safe here we all have to
disappear completely off the map they
decided to cut their movie production
schedule down to the release of two
films per year instead of three How to
Train Your Dragon the hidden world was
originally slated for 2016 but they
decided to push the release to the
summer of 2017 and then to the summer of
2018 now they are saying the movie will
be released in March of 2019 haters
gonna hate you guys may have missed it
but in How to Train Your Dragon 2 the
character named Gobber the belch came
out as gay with a brief little line in
the movie
oh you sir are playing a dangerous game
director Dean Dubois who is openly gay
said he thought it was a really fun and
daring move to put the line in he said
he loved the idea that Gobber is Burke's
resident gay but some haters out there
freaked out by gay characters in the
animated films one hate magazine said
the gay community was targeting children
hmm maybe Gobber will have a love
interest in the world what do you guys
think maybe dragons once existed in real
life it's likely that our ancient
ancestors found dinosaur bones and
thought they were dragon bones maybe
they created stories to try to
understand what they had discovered it's
possible that dragon like creatures used
to roam the earth but they probably
didn't breathe fire still an article in
BBC comm said when imagining dragons
people have always taken their cue from
reality in her book golden full Robin
hobb wrote that the skies of the world
were always meant to have dragons but
some children look up at the blue sky
and watch for something that never comes
thankfully we can turn our gaze to the
movie screens to fulfil this fantasy we
have to fight for their freedom
inevitable extinction in an interview
with slash film comm director Dean
Dubois shared that he was inspired by
the first words of precedent Cowell's
very first book in the series which was
hiccup as an adult reflected back the
line is there were dragons when I was a
boy Dubois said that there is something
really wonderful and bittersweet about a
specific era of time when dragons
existed in hints the fact that they are
going to tell us why we no longer see
dragons flying around in the sky the
dark secret will be revealed in the
movie this is goodbye for the How to
Train Your Dragon movie series and
speaking of endings the director reveal
that this will definitely be the last
film pertaining to these characters in
the How to Train Your Dragon series de
blah said that he's not interested in
continuing a franchise of these movies
so he puts the idea of a trilogy like
the original Star Wars movies he said
that he didn't want to keep going on
until people lost interest in the
characters so he created three movies
with the larger story that tells the
tale of hiccup from his young and
awkward days to the selfless chief he is
destined to be in the end what are your
favorite moments from the first two
movies
in the comments we hope you enjoyed
these dark secrets and fun facts about
How to Train Your Dragon the hidden
world thanks for watching the things see
you later
[Music]